David have you been reassured at all by
the notes
this is not the socialism of the past um
well it's not socialism of any kind I
mean that's that that that's the problem
with it I mean you're now under the
situation where socialism means exactly
what John or Angela tell you it me has
no kind of systemic value in it and and
it's really interesting from a from a
left point of view John's use of the use
of the word state just to kind of recap
it used to be a pretty fundamental tenet
that the state under capitalists is a
capita system was the capitalist state
and you wanted to get rid of it and then
you would create socialism and you'd
have a socialist state which was
different now everything that John's
talking about is how you get the
capitalist state to do the things that
you want it to do and in that and in
that sense all we're talking about here
is where effectively you draw the lines
what are the responsibilities of state
and government are they a bit more like
Sweden are they a bit more like Germany
are they a bit more like something else
if that's what you're discussing the
problem is that a significant number of
the people around Jeremy Corbyn grew up
and believed that there is something
much bigger than that and by the way if
there is what you want and I and I go a
long way with it I make I make this I
make these words John how can it
possibly be that you didn't discover
green politics till 2015 I mean I know
and why and what hold on and why should
the young people who now watch you
discovering it believe that they're not
better off with the Green Party you seem
to discover it several decades in other
words in other words I'm not I'm not
getting at you but in what sense of
but in what sense on what center the
Greens unsocial astride you in the green
party if that's what you're if that's
where it's taken you to well I think I'm
trying to say is that this this
abstraction the use of the word
socialism in this context it's not it's
not really very helpful and it's a way
of kind of maintaining links with the
past which wit which is very important
for the two people on my left here and
so on which actually are increasingly
not important to other people for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute's of Arts and
ideas at IAI TV
you